among an alien race called the move  lives a lonely fellow named oh hello who  was just trying to fit in  I am superstar in technology he needs  somewhere to hide up  can I come into the out now  no but I can you are just having to take  away the piece of wood this free face  honey I am oh oh I has been given this  name by my many many friends  your vehicle is infested he's my pet now  he's vibrating Boyd is he going to  explode he's on the rug why are they  after you I has made a few mistakes  oops he's in over his hole what is  happening to my body go dancing boov do  not dancing him down how long before  this kills me and he's looking for a  place to crash  from the creators of the truths and How  to Train Your Dragon did you really  think you could escape here here to  destroy the planet we're not giving up  he's changing he's changing his world  among booth I do not fit in nobody's  perfect  your mistakes what make you human okay